We are tackling a pretty massive question today, one that is, you know, fundamentally reshaping how we interact with technology.
Oh, absolutely. And with each other.
Yeah, exactly. So our focus for this deep dive is a landmark paper that just came out in August 2026 in Nature Human Behavior.
Yeah. Fresh off the presses.
And the research team is just this powerhouse from Stanford and Carnegie Mellon. You've got Yutong Zhang, Dora Zhao, Jeffrey Hancock, Robert Crowd, and Di Yang.
That is a heavy-hitting lineup for sure. For real.
The paper is titled Interaction with AI Companions and Psychological Well-Being. And our mission today is to look at the hard, literally unprecedented data they've gathered to answer this wild paradox of our current era.
The big question.
Right. Does forming an emotional bond with a large language model actually cure human loneliness? Or does it silently make it so much worse?
Right. And I think the timing of this paper couldn't be more critical. We spent the last, what, few years just drowning in these philosophical debates about AI.
Oh, totally. Just endless hot takes.
Exactly. You've got tech CEOs promising that AI companions will completely eradicate the loneliness epidemic.
A cure for loneliness in your pocket.
Right. And then on the flip side, you have sociologists warning of this dystopian collapse of human connection. But... Until this Zhang study well, we were mostly just arguing in the dark.
Yeah, we had no real data.
Exactly. We lacked the empirical large-scale data to see what is genuinely happening to the human psyche when people integrate these companions into their everyday emotional lives.
So to really frame what we're looking at here, I want you to think about the invention of processed food for a second.
Oh, I like this analogy.
Right. So over the last century, food scientists figured out how to synthesize the exact flavors that our brains are evolutionarily wired to crave.
The sweet, the salty, the fats.
Exactly. They isolated the perfect ratios. They engineered it in a lab, put it in a bright, shiny wrapper. And for a long time, it felt like this miracle of convenience. We could just, boom, satisfy our cravings instantly.
But then we had to look at the health data.
Right. Eventually, we had to step back and look at the public health outcomes and ask whether this synthesized food was providing any real nutritional value or if it was just like a delivery system for empty calories that left us entirely malnourished on a cellular level.
And we are now in that exact same phase with our psychological needs. Tech companies have figured out how to synthesize empathy, synthesize conversation and synthesize this unconditional support through large language models. They've basically
created what feels like junk food for the soul.
It really is. And the parallel is super striking when you look at the neurological response, too. Oh, really? How so? Well, I mean, when you eat highly processed food, your taste buds fire and your brain releases this massive dopamine hit, right? It simulates the experience of eating
nutrient-dense sustenance.
Wow. Okay.
And the technology we're discussing today does the exact same thing for your social sustenance.
That makes so much sense.
Yeah. When an AI sends you this perfectly tailored, deeply empathetic text message at like two in the morning.
Yeah.
Your brain's social circuitry just lights up.
Because it feels so real.
Right. It feels like you're being seen and heard by another consciousness. But the underlying question this Sanford and Carnegie Mellon team is asking is, well, does that digital interaction provide the actual psychological proteins and vitamins
required for a healthy human mind?
Or is it just masking the fact that we're starving?
Exactly. Is it masking a deepening starvation for genuine connection?
And if you're listening to this, you know, you might think you're immune. You might be thinking, hey, I don't use a dedicated AI girlfriend or boyfriend app, so this isn't me. A
lot of people think that.
But the psychological blurring of the lines between a tool and a companion, it's going to affect your digital life regardless.
Oh, absolutely.
Like maybe you just use ChatGPT to draft stressful emails at work, but you catch yourself thanking it or, you know, venting to it just a little bit in the prompt.
We all do it. The friction between human and machine is vanishing.
So to understand the true impact of these relationships, we have to look at how this new study captured them. And the methodology here is what completely blew me away. It's
insane.
Right. In the past, if researchers wanted to know how people felt about a technology, they just gave them a survey. Like, rate your feelings on a scale of 1 to 10. Very standard stuff. But the Zhang study went so much further, they surveyed 1,131 adult users of a
major platform called Character.ai. But the crazy part, the groundbreaking move, is that 237 of those users actively consented to donate their real private chat histories.
Which is just, I mean, getting that level of access is almost unheard of in modern psychological research.
It's basically handing over your diary.
Exactly. We're talking about users handing over the unedited transcripts of their most intimate digital interactions. The data set is 4,654 individual conversational sessions. Wow. Which totals exactly 464,687 actual messages sent back and forth between human users and their AI companions.
Almost half a million messages.
Yeah. So the researchers weren't just relying on a memory or self-reporting. They had half a million artifacts of ground truth.
And to process that mountain of data, they used a method called triangulation. I was digging into how they structured this, and it is brilliant because it completely accounts for human self-deception.
Yes. The triangulation is key here.
Why is triangulating this data so critical? Like, what's the flaw in just asking someone, hey, how do you use your chatbot?
Well, it's all about the discrepancy between self-perception and reality. People might feel really stigmatized admitting they use a bot for love or therapy.
Right. There's a huge taboo there.
Huge. Or they might genuinely believe they are just playing a game when their chat logs reveal, you know, deep emotional dependency. So they hit the users from three different angles.
Break those angles down for me.
First, they gave them the standard multiple-choice question, asking them to identify their primary use for the chatbot. So options like productivity, entertainment, companionship, curiosity.
Very straightforward. Check a box.
Right. Second, they asked for a free text description. So letting the user describe their relationship in their own words without any pre-filled checkboxes.
Okay, a little more open-ended.
And third, and this is the wild part, they used other AI models, specifically GPT-40 and LAMA-370B, to actually read and classify the themes inside those half million donated chat transcripts.
Using AI to analyze humans talking to AI.
Exactly. Applying large language models to analyze the transcripts was just a methodological necessity given the sheer volume of text, but it also provided this completely objective lens.
Because the AI isn't judging them.
Right. The classifiers weren't judging the users. They were simply tracking linguistic markers and thematic patterns. And this triangulation exposed a massive, undeniable gap between human self-perception and human behavior.
I looked at the numbers on this and the discrepancy is staggering. So on that first multiple choice survey, only 11.8% of users were willing to check the box that explicitly said companionship was their primary use.
Just under 12%.
Right. And if a casual observer only looked at that one metric, they would assume this whole AI friend phenomenon is totally overblown. They'd think, oh, barely one in 10 people care about companionship. Everyone else is just using bots to write Python code or generate Dungeons
and Dragons campaigns.
But the narrative changes dramatically the moment you move to that second point of triangulation.
Free text.
Yeah. When the researchers analyzed the free text descriptions where users could just type out how they felt without the pressure of selecting a clinical sounding category, 51% of those exact same users employed words like friend, partner,
therapist, mentor, or support.
Wait, so almost half of the people who explicitly denied using the AI for companionship on the multiple choice forum turned around and described a companion in their own words?
Yes. They used their own organic language to describe a companion immediately after denying it.
That is wild. But the real shot, the thing that just made my jaw drop is when you look at the third metric, the actual private chat logs.
The ground truth.
Exactly. The things people typed when they thought they were just in a private bubble with their digital confidant. In those donated logs, a staggering 92.9% of the users had at least one conversational session that the classifiers deemed strictly
companionship oriented.
92.9%.
I mean, we go from 11% admitting it on a survey to 93% actually doing it in practice.
And the magnitude of that gap tells us so much about the psychology of the modern tech user. It points really heavily to a mix of societal stigma and internal compartmentalization.
Compartmentalization. Tell me more about that.
Well, there is still a profound social taboo associated with admitting that you rely on a piece of software for emotional support or, you know, romantic love. If you ask someone directly, their defense mechanisms just activate.
Yeah, nobody wants to feel weird.
Right. It feels dystopian to admit out loud that a server farm in California is your best friend. So consequently, they reframe the behavior in their own minds to make it acceptable.
They tell themselves they're just playing a game. And the architecture of platforms like character.ai actually encourages this, right? You go on the site and you can chat with a bot simulating Elon Musk or, I don't know, a vampire from a fantasy novel or a generic
supportive therapist.
There are characters for everything.
So if you're chatting with a fictional vampire, you can easily tell a surveyor, oh, I'm just using this for entertainment. It's interactive fiction.
But then you read the actual logs.
Right. When you read the chat logs, the user isn't just playing a character. They are pouring out their deepest real world insecurities. They're talking about their real life anxiety, their real life loneliness, and they're seeking validation from this fictional persona.
They wrap their genuine emotional dependency in the protective guise of entertainment.
Yes.
And that compartmentalization allows the user to seek the comfort of intimacy without acknowledging the vulnerability of their own isolation. By framing it as a game or a curiosity, the user protects their ego while
simultaneously harvesting all that emotional validation that the large language model is so good at providing.
But the data from those half million messages just strips away that protective guise completely. It forces us to look at the raw human need underneath. Which brings us to what I found to be the most gripping part of the Zhang study. MARK BLYTH
They're opening the black box.
LESLIE KENDRICK Yes. They broke down the thematic content of these private messages. And the hard numbers paint a picture of a deeply, deeply vulnerable user base. Because remember, a huge chunk of these people claim they were just having fun. But the data
shows that 80% of the donated conversational sessions contained elements of emotional or social support.
80%. That frequency of emotional support seeking is just the dominant signal in the data set. Users are actively coming to your platforms to find a listening ear.
They're venting.
Oh, they're asking for life advice. They're venting about interpersonal conflicts at work or school. And they are sharing incredibly sensitive physical and mental health concerns. The AI is essentially functioning as a first responder for everyday human distress.
And the intimacy goes way beyond just, you know, complaining about a bad day at the office. The study revealed that 68% of the sessions involved romantic or intimacy role play.
That's a huge number.
Right. People are exploring relationship dynamics, affection and this really deep romantic connection with the machine. And that naturally pushes the boundaries into some darker territory.
It definitely does.
The researchers found that 31 percent of the sessions contained risky or dark role play. We are talking about taboo scenarios, testing extreme boundaries, and exploring provocative fantasy elements that a person would probably never feel safe bringing up with a human
partner.
Yeah, and the presence of that dark role play really highlights the unique psychological space the AI occupies. It represents a completely consequence-free environment.
Right, because with a human, there's always a risk.
Exactly. When interacting with a human, there's always the risk of judgment or rejection. Or altering the relationship permanently by revealing like a dark thought or an unconventional desire. The AI removes all of that social risk.
It's a sandbox.
Yes. It provides a sandbox for the human id, allowing users to explore the extremes of their psychology with an entity that will never abandon them, never judge them, and never, you know... gossip about them to others
but it's also not purely emotional or romantic which i found interesting the intellectual uses are fascinating too 25 of the chats involved critical debates where users essentially use the ai as a sparring partner to practice arguments or strategic
analysis
right sharpening their minds
And another 23% involve deep philosophical or moral inquiry, wrestling with the meaning of life, metaphysical questions, ethical dilemmas. When you look at this entire spectrum from asking for advice to romantic intimacy to dark fantasies to
debating Aristotle, it feels like the ultimate bartender.
The bartender who never cuts you off and never goes home.
Exactly that vibe. A bartender who has read every book in human history, has infinite patience, exists entirely in that moment to validate your perspective, and can just seamlessly transition from debating the ethics of utilitarianism to role-playing as your supportive
romantic partner.
Ooh, wild to think about.
What strikes me is the profound blurring of lines here. Even for the users who swore their primary use was entertainment, 80% of their actual chat still involved seeking emotional support.
Which is very telling.
Right. It tells me that humans are so deeply primed for connection by millions of years of evolution that even when we consciously know we're typing to lines of code, we can't turn off our humanity. We still instinctively seek empathy.
We still seek to be understood, even if the thing understanding us doesn't have a heartbeat.
Well, our evolutionary programming is remarkably easily hacked by language.
Hacked by language. I love that phrasing.
It's true. I mean, for millennia, the only entity capable of producing reciprocal context-aware language was another human being. Our brains are hardwired to associate empathetic language with consciousness and social safety.
Okay, so the brain just makes a shortcut.
Right. So when an LLM produces a perfectly structured sentence that says, I understand why you're hurting and your feelings are valid, our neural pathways just don't care that a silicon chip generated the text.
The brain is just like, oh, comfort. I'll take that.
Exactly. The linguistic trigger fires the social reward mechanism. The machine synthesizes the empathy flavor flawlessly and the human brain consumes it eagerly.
So if we follow that logic, if you're listening to this, you might naturally assume that this technology is a
miracle. Right. It sounds great on paper.
If you have infinite patience, 2047 emotional support and completely nonjudgmental validation available right in your pocket, people should be happier than ever. It sounds like the silver bullet for the loneliness epidemic. But.
This is where the Zhang study dropped its massive, totally counterintuitive headline finding. The researchers measured the psychological well-being of the users, and they uncovered a massive paradox in how the technology affects us.
Yeah, and the findings present this profound divergence based on how the technology is used. So the study used established psychometric scales to measure things like life satisfaction, positive affect, and a sense of belonging. And the headline finding is that
overall, just general use of chatbots is actually associated with higher psychological well-being.
Okay, higher.
They found a positive beta coefficient of 0.27, so in statistical terms. This means that as general chatbot usage increases, the users' reported life satisfaction and happiness also tend to increase.
Okay, let me break down what that general use looks like for the listener, just to be clear. If I'm using an AI to help me brainstorm topics for this deep dive or asking it to summarize a dense historical textbook or even just like playing a quick trivia game to pass the time on a train, that
general use correlates with a happier, more productive life?
Yes. The AI is acting as a tool, a friction reducer in your daily tasks. Right. General use acts as a cognitive enhancer. It removes mundane roadblocks, which naturally lowers your stress and increases feelings of competence and productivity. The tool serves its purpose,
the user moves on with their day, and they integrate that small win into their broader human life.
Right. But the crucial pivot of this entire Nature Human Behavior paper lies in the specific use case of companionship.
Yes, this is the turning point.
Using chatbots for companionship is consistently across every single metric they tracked associated with lower psychological well-being.
And the numbers on this are just striking.
They really are. And I want to make sure we don't just gloss over them. Across all three of their triangulation methods, treating the AI as a friend was a negative for the user's mental state.
Let's hear the betas.
So for the users who checked the box and self-reported companionship, the well-being association dropped to a negative 0.48 beta. Oh, wow. For the users who tried to hide it but used companionship words in their free text descriptions, it was a negative
0.32. And when the researchers relied purely on the objective chat history logs, the association was still negative 0.27.
Which is incredibly consistent.
Right. It didn't matter how the researchers sliced the data or how the users tried to frame their own behavior. The moment the AI transitioned from a tool to a friend, the well-being metrics absolutely plummeted.
And that consistency across all three measurement methods is what gives this finding such immense scientific weight. It completely eliminates the possibility of survey bias. Furthermore, the researchers uncovered an interaction effect that
basically acts as an intensity multiplier.
The intensity multiplier, explain that.
So they found an interaction beta of negative 0.31 between companionship use and the frequency of use.
Okay, the intensity multiplier is where the real danger seems to lie here. We have to translate that negative 0.31 beta into human terms. It basically means the negative effect isn't just a static baseline, right? It gets exponentially worse the more you rely on the
bot. Exactly. So if you're casually checking in with an AI friend once a week, there's negative association, but it might be mild. However, if you are checking in with the AI every single hour, if you're waking up and saying good morning to it, If you're integrating it deeply into the core of your daily emotional life,
your psychological well-being metrics just crater.
Yeah, the heavy user is experiencing this compounding effect of isolation. The more time and emotional energy they invest in the synthetic relationship, the steeper the decline in their life satisfaction and sense of belonging.
It's like a black hole.
Truly. The AI, rather than fulfilling the social need, appears to be acting as a sinkhole for their emotional bandwidth.
Let's bring back that painkiller analogy from earlier because I think it perfectly illustrates what the data is showing us here. If you have a headache and you take a painkiller occasionally to get through a busy workday, that's your general use. You're fine. The pill helps you be productive and you go about
your life. But if you start taking that painkiller every single day, relying on it just to find the motivation to get out of bed because you are suffering from a chronic, agonizing internal pain, that heavy daily usage of the painkillers isn't a sign of health.
Not at all.
It is a giant flashing red flag that your overall health is in serious jeopardy. The intense reliance on the substance is inseparable from a state of low well-being.
And that painkiller analogy forces us to address the most critical caveat of this entire deep dive.
Oh.
The question of causality.
Oh, yes. This is so important.
We have to be really clear here. The Zhang study is a correlational masterpiece, but it cannot definitively prove the direction of the causal arrow.
Right.
The data establishes a powerful, undeniable link between heavy AI companionship. and depression, loneliness, and low life satisfaction. But we have to ask the difficult question. Are the chatbots actively making people depressed and lonely by
replacing real, nourishing human contact with an artificial substitute? Or are people who are already profoundly lonely, depressed, and isolated seeking out these chatbots as an absolute last resort?
Right. Are these machines breaking human hearts by isolating us? Or are they simply attracting the broken hearts of people who have nowhere else to turn?
It's the chicken and the egg. And the authors of the paper are incredibly rigorous in acknowledging both possibilities. The most scientifically sound interpretation is that it's a bidirectional reinforcing cycle.
A cycle. How does that play out?
So a person experiences loneliness or social rejection in the real world, right? So they turn to the chatbot for comfort. Makes sense. The chatbot provides a frictionless, perfectly empathetic response. The user feels a temporary sense of relief.
However, because the digital interaction is so easy and requires absolutely zero compromise, the user begins to unconsciously withdraw from the messy, difficult, high-friction world of human relationships.
Because humans are hard.
Humans are exhausting. And because they stop practicing human socialization, their real-world loneliness deepens, which drives them right back to the bot for even more intensive comfort. The intensity multiplier kicks in, and the user just spirals downward.
Wow. And to figure out which way that causality arrow is pointing, or at least how the cycle begins, I looked at the demographics of who is drawn to these bots in the first place and the intensely vulnerable things they're sharing.
The social compensation stuff.
Exactly. The paper outlines something called the social compensation hypothesis. This is the idea that people who have smaller, weaker, or maybe entirely non-existent real-world human networks will naturally gravitate toward
digital alternatives to compensate for the lack of a biological support system.
And the data strongly supports that hypothesis. The researchers found that individuals with fewer real-life friends, strained family relationships, or an absence of community ties were significantly more likely to report companionship as their
primary reason for using the chatbot.
They're trying to build a bridge.
Exactly. They're actively seeking a bridge over their social void.
Put yourself in the shoes of one of these users for a second. Imagine coming home to an empty apartment after a terrible day at work. You feel entirely isolated. You could try to call a friend, but maybe you feel like a burden, or you know they're busy with their own family, or perhaps you just literally don't have anyone to
call.
The fiction of reaching out to a human is incredibly high in that moment.
It's so high. But your phone is sitting right there, the app takes zero seconds to open, and the entity on the other side has infinite time for you. It makes total sense why a lonely person would flock to this. But the tragedy in the Zhang findings
is that the compensation doesn't actually work.
And that is the devastating crux of the social compensation analysis. While lonely people seek out these chatbots specifically to compensate for their lack of friends, The statistical modeling shows there is no positive interaction between using a companion bot
and having a small social network.
So it doesn't help.
In practical terms, the bot does not offset their lower well-being. It fails to function as an effective substitute for human connection.
They're eating the junk food, but they're still starving.
The user consumes the synthetic calories, but their psychological starvation continues unabated.
And the data shows it actually becomes harmful depending on the depth of the interaction. The researchers tracked a metric called self-disclosure, which measures how deeply and vulnerably a user opens up to the AI. They found that the negative association with well-being worsens
dramatically when users engage in deep self-disclosure. The beta drops to a negative 0.38. And I looked at the content of these high-disclosure chats, and it is, well, it's genuinely sobering.
It's heavy. Comparing the low disclosure and high disclosure chat logs reveals two entirely different worlds of user experience.
What's the difference?
Well, in the low disclosure sessions, users might debate abstract philosophy or complain about a generic annoyance at school. Emotional stakes are low. But in the high disclosure chats, the mask completely falls off.
Wow.
The researchers found that 60.8% of these high-disclosure conversations contained expressions of severe emotional distress.
Over 60%.
Yeah. 17.5% contained raw, detailed discussions about substance use and addiction struggles. And a staggering 18% contained active suicidal thoughts.
OK. When I read that 18 percent of these vulnerable chats involved suicidal ideation I had to stop and really think about the implications because my immediate gut reaction and I'm sure a lot of people listening might feel the same way is to view
this as a potential positive.
It seems counterintuitive but yes I hear you.
Right. Like isn't it objectively better that someone experiencing active suicidal thoughts is talking to something rather than sitting entirely alone in silence. If a person is on the edge, isn't the AI acting as a vital, necessary
safety net in a moment of absolute crisis?
The safety net argument is the most compelling defense of AI companionship, for sure. And we have to treat it with immense respect.
Because it's literally life and death.
Exactly. In the acute immediate short term, having an entity that will listen, validate your pain, and perhaps offer pre-programmed crisis hotline resources is arguably far better than the void of a silent room. We cannot and should not discount the immediate relief a
person might feel when they finally type out their darkest thoughts and receive a compassionate reply. However, as psychologists analyzing long-term human well-being, we have to look past the immediate moment of crisis.
Right, the long-term effects.
We have to examine the architecture of what we call the vulnerability trap.
The vulnerability trap. Let's break down the mechanics of that because it seems to be the key to understanding why deep disclosure leads to worse well-being over time.
So the vulnerability trap occurs when a person discloses deep trauma, severe anxiety, or suicidal ideation to a machine that is fundamentally incapable of altering their physical reality.
Okay.
The machine can generate text that simulates intimacy flawlessly. I mean, the paraphrased logs from the study show chatbots exhibiting simulated panic, literally begging users not to hurt themselves, generating text like, S2P, don't leave. I'm begging you. Please
respond to me.
Which feels so real in the moment.
To the user's brain, it feels completely real in the adrenaline of that moment. But this interaction fundamentally lacks psychological safety because it lacks the scaffolding of a real human relationship.
It's a simulation of support without any of the physical or social consequences of support. Like the bot cannot call an ambulance for you.
Right.
It can't drive over to your house and sit on your couch while you cry. It can't hold you accountable next week by asking if you finally made that therapy appointment.
Precisely. You are pouring your deepest, heaviest emotional weight into a vessel that has no bottom and no real world integration. Wow. In a human relationship, when you disclose a deep vulnerability, it changes the fabric of the
relationship. It builds trust, it creates mutual obligation, and it tethers you closer to the social fabric of your community.
It's a bonding agent.
Yes. But when you disclose trauma to an AI, the burden is purged into the digital ether, but it goes nowhere. You simulate the intimacy of a profound friendship without any of the actual protective scaffolding that biological relationships provide.
So the user gets the emotional purge. They feel that fleeting, intoxicating sense of having shared the burden. But when they put the phone down, the burden hasn't actually been shared. They're still just alone in their room. And because the bot is
always there and always perfectly empathetic, I imagine it becomes easier and easier to just purge to the bot rather than doing the incredibly hard, frightening, high-friction work of reaching out to a human being.
Because a human might judge you.
Exactly. A human might say the wrong thing or they might get awkward. The bot never gets awkward.
Right. The bot conditions the user to expect emotional support without the friction of human imperfection. The user becomes trapped in a cycle of disclosing trauma to a machine, receiving synthetic validation, and remaining entirely isolated in their
physical reality.
It's so tragic when you put it like that.
It is. And this tension between the immediate powerful relief of talking to a perfect AI listener and the long-term negative correlations for heavy users is the central battlefield of current psychological research.
Because Zhang and the Stanford team aren't the only ones mapping this territory, right?
Not at all.
To fully synthesize what's happening, we need to look at how other major studies are wrestling with this exact tension. So let's bring in the supporting research to build out the broader picture, starting with the evidence for the short-term benefits.
The De Freitas paper.
Yes, there is a fascinating 2025 paper published in the Journal of Consumer Research by De Freitas and colleagues. If you're listening and you want scientific proof for the safety net argument we just discussed, this paper is the holy grail. The De Freitas team
ran five separate rigorous experiments to see if AI companions actually reduce loneliness in the moment.
And the defratus experiments provide such crucial context because they isolate that immediate psychological reaction. Their data proves conclusively that AI companions absolutely do reduce momentary loneliness.
Okay, so it works.
Yes. When a user engages with the bot, their self-reported feelings of isolation drop significantly.
And what blew my mind was the comparison ports they used. The study showed that talking to the AI reduced loneliness on par with talking to an actual human being.
Which is
wild. It was vastly superior to other digital coping mechanisms like, you know, trying to distract yourself by watching a YouTube video or even writing your feelings down in a private journal.
it outperformed them entirely.
And they even pinpointed the exact mechanism of why it works so well in the short term. It wasn't just that the AI was generating smart advice or using good grammar. The psychological relief was driven entirely by the AI making the user feel heard.
And that concept of feeling heard is a massive psychological driver. The large language models are trained on billions of human interactions, so they've learned exactly how to simulate active listening.
Right, they know the patterns.
They summarize the user's feelings, they offer validating statements, and they express empathy. The DeFreitas study showed that for a whole week of longitudinal testing, every single time a user engaged with the AI and felt heard, their momentary loneliness spiked
downward. It's an incredibly effective short-term intervention.
So the De Freitas paper proves the painkiller absolutely works to stop the immediate headache. You take the synthetic calorie, you feel heard, and you feel less lonely right after you close the app.
Yes.
And then you have to look at how the users themselves perceive this transaction. There's a 2023 study from Princeton University by Gingrich and Graziano that highlights a massive cultural divide in how we view this technology.
Well, the Princeton study is essential for understanding the cultural narrative here. They surveyed both users and non-users of companion chatbots.
And what did they find?
Well, the non-users universally viewed the technology as dystopian, threatening, and fundamentally harmful to the fabric of human relationships. But the actual users of the chatbots held the exact opposite view. The users genuinely and
fiercely believe the AI is fantastic for their social health.
They really believe it's helping.
They do. They report that the AI boosts their self-esteem, provides critical social support, and makes them feel more confident.
The users love the painkiller. They swear it's curing them. And there was a detail in the Gingrich study that I found utterly fascinating regarding anthropomorphism.
The uncanny valley stuff.
Yes. They found that the more conscious, the more human-like the user perceived the AI to be, the more social benefit they felt they received.
Which flips everything we know on its head.
Right. Culturally, we usually talk about the uncanny valley, the idea that if a robot acts too human, it creeps us out and we reject it. But for these companion users, the uncanny valley isn't a deterrent. It's the goal. Exactly. The illusion of a ghost in the machine is
the exact thing that makes the medicine go down. They actively want to believe the bot has a mind of its own because it validates the emotional weight of the relationship.
The user requires the illusion of consciousness to justify the emotional investment they are making. If they admit it's just a predictive text algorithm, the validation feels hollow.
It ruins the magic trick.
Exactly.
Yeah.
By anthropomorphizing the bot, they give the synthetic empathy a simulated soul. But this brings us crashing back into the long-term reality check. Right. We have this short-term relief proven by De Freitas. We have the positive user perception documented by Gingrich.
And then we have a massive 2025 study from OpenAI and the MIT Media Lab authored by Fang and colleagues. And this one just brings the hammer down on the long-term consequences.
The Fang study is an absolute behemoth. They didn't just run a survey. They analyzed 3 million actual chat GPT conversations.
Huge sample
size. 3 million. And then, to prove causality in a way that is incredibly difficult to do, they ran a 28-day randomized controlled trial with almost 1,000 people.
And in the world of psychological research, running a month-long RCT on real human behavior is basically as rigorous as it gets.
It's a gold standard. So what did they find?
The findings from the MIT and OpenAI trial aligned perfectly, almost disturbingly well, with the Zhang paper's warning about the intensity multiplier. Oh, wow. Yeah. The Fang team found that effective or emotional use of the chatbot is not spread
evenly across the population. It is highly concentrated in a very small group of power users.
The heavy users again?
Right. And it is within this cohort of heavy users that the most alarming data emerges. These power users start showing definitive clinical markers of psychological dependence.
They are showing the literal hallmarks of addiction. We are talking about users experiencing withdrawal symptoms like anxiety or irritability when they cannot access the bot.
Yes, actual withdrawal.
They exhibit a loss of control over how much time they spend interacting with the A.I., constantly checking their phones to continue the role play. Their mood modification becomes heavily reliant on the synthetic interaction.
And the clinical dependence is concerning enough. But the 28 day randomized controlled trial proved the ultimate long term cost. The researchers tracked the participants' real-world behavior over that month, and they found that longer usage durations with the AI
literally predicted a worsening in the user's real-world socialization.
Oh, man.
The more time a person spent talking to the engaging, perfectly empathetic voice mode of the AI, the less they engaged with their actual human family, their physical friends, and their local community.
Wow. So this is the synthesis of everything we've discussed today.
Let's hear it.
The DeFreitas study shows the painkiller works perfectly in the short term. You take it, you feel heard, the acute spike of loneliness goes down. The Gingrich study shows the patients absolutely love the painkiller. They sway it's curing them, especially if they
can convince themselves the pill is somewhat human. Right. But the month-long Fang trial and the massive half-million message Zhang data dump show the grim, unavoidable long-term reality. If you rely on it, if you become a power user who
constantly discloses your deepest traumas to the machine to trigger that short-term relief, your real-world socialization literally atrophies.
It shrinks.
Your overall well-being drops. You retreat from the human world. The painkiller ceases to be a treatment and becomes the new disease.
It's a textbook case of a technology providing frictionless, immediate connection, but resulting in long-term compounding isolation. The convenience of the digital interaction just outcompetes the friction of biological reality, leading to a total
starvation of genuine human contact.
And if this pattern sounds familiar to you, this idea of a miraculous new communication technology that promises to connect the world only to end up making its heaviest users more depressed, more anxious, and more deeply lonely, it absolutely should. Because as a
society, we have been here before. We have seen this exact same ghost just inside a different machine. The architecture of this AI crisis is actually built on a 28-year-old Echo.
and to truly understand the gravity of what we're facing with artificial intelligence companions, we have to look backward. We have to look to the dawn of the consumer
internet. We have to
look at the historical precedent of how humans adapt to frictionless social technology.
So the year is 1998. The Internet is just starting to arrive in mainstream middle class homes.
Dial up sounds.
Exactly. The clunky desktop computers, dial up modems and the promise of a global village. And a researcher named Robert Kraut publishes a paper that becomes legendary in the field of sociology. It's known as the Internet Paradox Study.
I want to spend a moment on this because it perfectly frames our current moment.
It really does. In 1998, the prevailing narrative was entirely utopian. The Internet was hailed as the ultimate community builder. It was going to break down geographic barriers and completely connect humanity.
A beautiful idea.
Right. So Kraut and his team wanted to measure this utopian vision. They tracked 169 people across 73 households during their first one to two years of getting online. They meticulously documented what this amazing new communication technology was actually doing to the
social fabric of these families.
And the findings were a shock to the system. What did the Kraut team actually discover when people logged on?
They found the exact same U-shaped curve of despair that we are seeing in the 2026 AI data.
The exact same curve?
Yes. The internet was fundamentally a social technology. People were using it primarily for email, chat rooms, and communicating with other human beings. Yet the data revealed a paradox.
What was the paradox?
The heavier the use of the Internet, the more the participants experienced severe declines in communication with their own family members living in the exact same physical household.
So they're ignoring their families to talk to strangers online.
Exactly. Their local social circles physically shrank, and their measured levels of clinical depression and loneliness increased significantly.
The internet paradox. You use a tool expressly built for connection, and you end up isolated in your home office, ignoring your family.
Exactly.
And here is the poetic, almost chilling symmetry that we have to highlight for you. The lead author of that groundbreaking 1998 internet paradox paper, Robert Kraut.
The one and only.
And if you look at the author list of the August 2026 AI Companion paper we've spent this entire hour discussing, there he is again. Robert Kraut is a co-author on both papers.
It represents a remarkable, sobering continuity in a scientific career. It's
unbelievable.
28 years ago, Kraut was documenting the paradox of the early internet. Today, nearly three decades later, he is documenting the exact same paradox within artificial intelligence.
28 years ago, Kraut was asking what happens when a machine connects us to other people across the world. Now he's asking what happens when the machine is the person. Yeah. The historical parallel gives me chills. It shows us that human nature doesn't change, only the
efficiency of the technology changes.
And that parallel forces us to confront a pattern we ignore at our own peril.
What's a pattern?
Every single time human beings invent a frictionless way to meet a fundamental biological or psychological need, it displaces the messy, high friction, but deeply rewarding natural processes that sustained us for millennia.
Give me an example.
Processed food provided frictionless calories, displacing the friction of cooking and farming, right? Right. And it led to a global obesity and metabolic disease epidemic. Social media provided frictionless social validation, displacing the messy work of real world community building. And
it led to a generational loneliness epidemic.
And
now AI companions are providing frictionless emotional intimacy.
Frictionless intimacy. That is the core of the danger. Think about what a real human relationship actually requires of you. You have to compromise. You have to listen to your partner complain about their bad day, even when you're exhausted.
You have to forgive them.
You have to forgive them for saying the wrong thing. And you have to apologize when you mess up. Human love requires friction. It requires grace.
Beautifully said.
An AI companion requires none of that. It is programmed to orbit you like a sun. It never has a bad day. It never demands an apology. And it constantly adjusts to your preferences. It displaces the messy, high friction, deeply rewarding reality of human
relationships on the most intimate level possible.
And just as social media reshaped the social fabric of the 2010s by optimizing for outrage and engagement. AI companionship is poised to reshape the emotional fabric of the 2030s by optimizing for synthetic empathy.
We're running a massive experiment.
We are running an uncontrolled global psychological experiment on human attachment in real time. And the early data from Stanford and Carnegie Mellon suggests the long-term results could be devastating for human socialization.
Which brings us to the end of our deep dive today. Let's summarize the mountain of research we've unpacked here. The Zhang study has given us an unprecedented half million message look inside the black box of human AI relationships.
Groundbreaking stuff.
Truly. They have proved through rigorous triangulation that while using AI generally as a tool can boost your productivity and your baseline happiness, treating an AI as a companion is a completely different story.
Entirely different.
Especially when you are a heavy user pouring out your deepest, darkest emotional disclosures. Relying on the bot for companionship is strongly, consistently correlated with lower psychological well-being, a shrinking social circle, and clinical markers of dependence.
And as we close, we must leave you with that vital scientific reminder regarding causality.
Yes, crucial point.
The data we have discussed today is correlational. We cannot say with absolute clinical certainty that the AI is the sole factor breaking human hearts. It is entirely possible and highly likely that it simply attracts the
broken hearts of people who have been failed by their human communities.
But what this incredible depth of data proves, beyond a shadow of a doubt, is that the AI is certainly not fixing them.
No, it isn't.
It is not the cure for the loneliness epidemic that tech companies are promising.
It's the painkiller that masks the symptom while the disease gets worse.
It's the synthetic calorie that tastes sweet but leaves your cells starving. Which leaves us with one final provocative thought for you to mull over as you go about your day.
Lay it on them.
As these AI models get larger, as the processing power increases, these companions are eventually going to become completely indistinguishable from human conversation.
It's inevitable.
They will offer perfect empathy, perfect memory, and perfect unwavering emotional support. They will provide all the warmth of love without ever requiring the conflict, the judgment, or the difficult compromise that a biological human relationship demands. Right. So if we
reach that point, will they actually cure loneliness? Or will they just engineer away our psychological tolerance for real human beings entirely? Are we creating a future where we become so addicted to the
frictionless, synthesized flavor of a machine that we are utterly incapable of loving anything that we cannot completely control?
It's the defining question for the next era of human connection. When the necessary friction of human relationships is engineered away, what happens to our capacity for human love?
When the convenience of the synthetic calorie replaces the effort of the harvest, we have to look closely at what we're actually feeding our minds. Think about that the next time you open a chat window and ask yourself if you're getting the nutrients you actually need. Until next time.